all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking up with something
besides the x-men i feel like it's been
a while since we covered anything else
in marvel comics right we've done
immortal hulk we've done the x-men and i
feel like that's largely been it so what
i want to do here is i want to cover
iron man because we essentially have the
return of what is one of the most
powerful cosmic entities in existence
kind of but not really you guys will see
what i'm talking about right it's
actually one of the coolest things ever
and i'm curious to see if you guys can
figure it out before i tell you who it
is so this largely comes or really kind
of picks up with a bit of a conflict
between iron man and terrax now terrax
as a lot of you guys know is a
long-standing villain in the history of
marvel comics he was at one point a
herald of galactus these days he's small
time right you don't really see him
being that big of a deal anymore and
even then when you saw him in hickman's
avengers the new avengers run he was
really more of just a plot device just
kind of there for the sake of telling a
story and and so on and so forth and
that's largely been his role in marvel
comics really since the 80s but terrax
is taken out quite readily but one of
the things that we end up learning here
is that tony stark has left his own
company stark unlimited now this is
business as usual we've seen this happen
multiple times over the course of marvel
comics but the way that christopher
cantwell's doing this is really really
cool right christopher cantwell is a guy
who's currently writing iron man i was a
little on the fence when i heard he was
taking it over i do not regret reading
it his writing is amazing he's really
really cool with this but one of the
things that happens is he ends up
getting a kind of 65 billion dollar
severance package which is nice and then
from there like in his fight with terrax
he ends up like destroying a satellite
right and then of course he gets a whole
bunch of flack and a whole bunch of heat
on social media now one of the things
that any youtuber will tell you or
social media influencer will tell you is
take what people say on social media
with a grain of salt social media is an
answer to the question what happens when
people can say what they want without
consequences and social media will
basically show you what people are
really like right so it's kind of
interesting at the end of the day tony
stark seems to kind of get caught up in
a social media to a degree but one of
the things that he's also kind of kind
of criticized for and grilled for a
little bit is the idea of him changing
his career when he's like you know what
i'm stepping away from technology
completely machines should be building
machines we need to get back in touch
with what it means to be human and she's
like when you say get back in touch with
your roots are you talking about the 65
billion dollar exit package from stark
unlimited a 14.8 million malibu mansion
and a computerized iron man suit
this is dangerous as a thermonuclear
weapon is that getting back to your
roots is that what you're referring to
because if you're talking about becoming
an average man they don't have any of
that
so it's kind of a funny little thing
there but social media largely seems to
have it out for right you know it's kind
of kind of taking it to him but you kind
of get these little tidbits here and
there he kind of packs everything up
right he's kind of telling rhodey like
pack everything up right he's got his
1970 boss 429 mustang which i always
thought was kind of cool but i'm more of
a 1971 chevelle 450 big block man myself
it's my dream car
but it's kind of this thing where tony
stark's sort of just walking away from
it all right just literally leaving it
all behind and it's just like i want to
get back to a simpler life and that kind
of makes sense right i mean it is very
difficult to look at a person who's a
billionaire and see that like you know
man life must be a struggle for them but
it's one of these things where a
person's struggles aren't necessarily
based on money oftentimes they're just
based on their life experiences right
the things they go through and if you're
somebody like iron man you've never had
a moment's peace and you're kind of
cursed with a gift of knowledge to a
degree but you're always out there doing
something right you're always putting
your life on the line there's all these
kind of threats that go on time and time
again it makes sense that there comes a
point when you're like you know what i
just want to be done with it all right
just buy some brownstone and just live
some measure of a peaceful life and so
tony stark kind of starts to get a
little bit reckless or what you would
expect a guy like him to do if he's just
sort of getting out there and just doing
things that he always thought would be
fascinating like for example getting
involved in a street race now as you
guys know from watching fast and the
furious nothing in this world is
stronger than family not even galactus
family can be galactus family can beat
cosmic entities thanos would have been
defeated with the infinity stones and
the infinity gauntlet had family stepped
in but tony stark ain't involved in
these street races and so on he's just
kind of being reckless i mean to a
degree like he puts like five grand on
the line just to get involved in a race
with this guy but while all this is
happening small little things are taking
place right small little moments are
going on behind the scenes robberies
break-ins and normally tony stark would
never really concern himself with this
but then we get the appearance of a
relatively interesting character right
he kind of tweets out that he's holding
a kind of a get together with some old
friends and he ends up being met with
the arrival of patsy walker hellcat now
patsy walker was a huge deal back in the
day right like back in the 70s and 80s
she was a huge deal and she's really
been around for a long long time in
marvel but the reality is she's just
kind of been small peanuts for a long
time and that's one of the things that i
want you guys to notice with what
christopher cantwell's doing here is a
lot of these old old-school small-time
guys he's bringing him back right he's
bringing back a lot of these old-school
small-time characters and it's kind of
interesting because the relationship
between patsy walker and iron man is
such that they had a kind of romantic
interest at one point a bit of a fling
but there's history there but in the
middle of them talking and having this
conversation suddenly he's met by the
arrival of a guy named fuller tile hard
i think that's how you pronounce it
that's how i pronounce it ortil hard
whatever this guy basically has this
business proposition now this is almost
kind of a shot for shot of iron man 3
when you had a when he had killian who
approached tony stark was like i had
this really cool idea you guys remember
that whole scene from iron man 3 i know
you guys try to block the movie out of
your head but uh this is kind of a
shot-for-shot moment of that when he
basically pitches this idea to him they
could really change everything right
capturing lightning and the whole idea
behind that is lightning is an
exceedingly powerful source of energy
and it's naturally occurring so why not
harness that and then basically use like
waste free energy that can power the
world right they can do all kinds of
things to fix the world now the reality
is tony stark isn't necessarily against
this because he's like i mean there's no
real profit to be made here or i can't
weaponize it or anything like that it's
largely because one he's wearing fuzzy
bunny slippers and two he just doesn't
really care about that kind of stuff
anymore it doesn't really seem to be
relevant to him anymore and so he's like
i mean lightning's cool you know that's
that's whatever and then just kind of
walks away with with patsy walker you
know this guy's kind of like well let me
know if you ever decide to change your
mind let me know that will be incredibly
important and the reason why is because
iron man getting back to his roots is
not necessarily him walking away from
the role of iron man and in fact he
actually breaks out a vintage suit from
back in the day when he was simply just
the golden avenger right an old school
iron man suit that in the eyes of tony
stark there's almost a kind of level of
humanity that's lost with the advent of
technology and there's really no one
better to make that case than him right
the average person on twitter is not
equipped to make that case a futurist a
person who's developed some of the most
advanced technologies in the world and
in fact the foremost authority on
technology is equipped to make that
argument because he understands the full
breadth of what technology has done for
and to society and what it will lead to
that's one of the things to keep in mind
iron man's always been a futurist right
tony stark has always looked to the
future he builds for tomorrow he doesn't
build for today and that's why
technologically even comparing him to
people like reed richards or like
wakanda or something like that he's
usually always a step ahead of them it's
one of the things that was established
during and at the end of jonathan
hickman's avengers new avengers run is
that in comparison to everybody else out
there t'challa reed richards all these
guys even peter parker to a degree or
even dr octopus iron man's ahead of all
of them right just in terms of his
ability to develop technologies the only
thing that limits him is the technology
around him right what he can build based
on the existing resources that he has
but if he were to go to wakanda and he
had all the resources in wakanda it
would dwarf everything that wakanda's
built already i mean wakanda never
really had the ability to build a dyson
sphere tony stark did right you
literally build one around the sun it
was one of the most monumental
achievements and he had to use alien
technology in order to pull it off it's
one of these things where he kind of
sits down and he has this bit of a
conversation with patsy walker and he
starts out kind of kind of having this
bit of an existential crisis i don't
really know who i am anymore when she
asks the question like what's the whole
point behind this right what's the whole
idea behind leaving technology behind
walking away from stock unlimited and
then living more of a peaceful life and
just kind of going back to the days when
it was just you and iron man and that
was basically it what's the point behind
all this right why are you even hanging
out with me like we haven't hung out in
forever and the response to tony is i
don't know who i am anymore right i
don't really know what my deal is
anymore i don't know my purpose in all
of this right an existential crisis on
behalf of tony stark and that's when in
the middle of all this they suddenly
realize that unicorn is is launching a
heist
now you're probably asking your question
who's unicorn and rightfully so unicorn
hasn't been relevant in decades and when
i say decades i mean decades but you
know unicorn is a guy with super
strength right he can lift something
like 15 tons if my memory serves me
correctly he's pretty powerful right
he's a very easy he's a strong character
but he is if there was something lower
than a z-list villain it would be him
but the crazy thing is the whole time
he's doing this he keeps referencing a
guy called the other right and he's
literally stolen this book from a
library of all places right it's like
why would this guy break into a library
and steal a book but the other thing is
there's a bit of a few kind of
enhancements here enough that he's able
to really hold his own against iron man
kind of subdue him for a second and then
ultimately escape but not before iron
man basically you know knocks down the
helicopter since they crash into the
ground and then basically you know
unicorn is arrested and iron man
realizes what he's stolen here is the
gutenberg bible now this is the weirdest
thing to steal because the significance
of the gutenberg bible is it was the
first book that was printed with the
gutenberg press which started the
process of just mass producing books
using machinery but the fact that this
is being stolen by some guy like unicorn
it doesn't make any sense right it's
like why like you know why would you do
this and who's the other right who's
this being that you're referring to and
so what you end up doing is you actually
switch over to this guy that that iron
man had been talking to previously and
this guy's just kind of standing in a
window staring out now if you look at
this bottom panel here anybody who knows
anything about the history of marvel
comics will be able to tell you right
off the bat who this guy is right if you
ever read the history of marvel i mean
if the artwork tells you who this guy is
but for those of you guys who are unsure
and those of you guys who have not been
able to guess it yet you pick up one
year prior to all of this and basically
this this system is kind of brought
online right this being is basically
brought online by the enclave now those
of you guys who don't really know what
the enclave is they are significant
right they're hugely significant the
enclave were the ones who basically
developed adam warlock the idea behind
the enclave is basically they're a
collection of scientists who want to run
the world right who want to like conquer
the world focusing on like science and
technology as opposed to having some
kind of nefarious purpose right they're
not really looking to be like you know
dictators that rule the world with an
iron fist they just kind of believe that
humanity is its problem and that forcing
humanity to exist on a more scientific
and technological level would basically
make the world better the other part of
this is that this guy's referred to as
adam four again kind of picking up from
the adam warlock project that adam
warlock would be referred to as adam one
and they've had various attempts over
the years to duplicate adam warlock
right kismet is a perfect example of
that but this guy says do not call me
adam call me by my real name korvac so
this is kind of a crazy thing the return
of michael korvac and they asked like
what's your mission and it's like you
know something about saving the enclave
i don't know but your mission is selfish
right like and this is this is one of
the cool coolest things he says here he
says what makes humans so arrogant as to
think their world is more important than
any other why make the world a better
place why not make the universe a better
place a better reality for everybody
who's here and this guy responds and
says you're a cybernetic amalgamation
you're superior opinions on these
matters are beneath you it's your nearly
unlimited intellect that is required and
before he can finish he says it's my
nearly unlimited intellect that tells me
this universe is a landfill that is
conflict-laden and wartworn by the
greedy it tells me that this is the
reality that while filled with those
proclaiming to be gods is ultimately
godless and lost and ultimately it tells
me that i am but mere steps away from
becoming the god that it needs you can
have your enclave i have bigger plans
and i must begin immediately now this is
the bane of the existence when it comes
to the enclave when they originally made
adam warlock they had to fly in alicia
masters right the blind girlfriend of
ben grimm because the light emitting
from adam warlock was too bright for
them to see and they had to know if
their experiment was a success but
almost immediately after adam warlock
emerged he turned against the enclave
fought alongside the fantastic four and
then bolted and then he kidnapped siff
and tried to marry her which is kind of
weird but it's the the bane of the
existence of the enclave that every
organism that they either manufacture or
alter ends up turning against them
because honestly despite the the fact
that they exist based on the beliefs of
science and technology they defy logic
and reason in terms of their motivation
and why they want to do what they do and
so switching back over to iron man
suddenly he's basically caught up in
murder world right now we don't really
know exactly how he got here and even
iron man says i don't know how i'm here
it's just him and crusher creole that
were snatched up and brought to this
place and crusher creel's like if i have
to destroy you in order to get out of
here and that's exactly what i'll do
iron man ends up figuring out that it
was basically arcade and then of course
once they unmask rk they end up freeing
themselves and so on but this is going
towards the kind of continued crushing
of iron man as far as public opinion
goes that iron man is doing things that
the general public doesn't like and so
the general public is turning against
him whether it's logical or reasonable
is irrelevant right that it doesn't
really matter whether or not what people
believe is logical and reasonable it's
just what they believe and people will
steadfast their beliefs and very rarely
ever change them unless they absolutely
have to and it's only really in the face
of conflict or destruction that they
have to change their opinions but you
end up having this kind of situation
over and over and over again this is
what's happening time and time again
there's these different villains that
are showing up here right one guy
kidnaps a whole bunch of guys from stark
unlimited and tony stark has to go in
and save them you know it's just this
kind of situation this kind of process
that repeats itself continually that you
end up having iron man who basically
kind of saves the day albeit you know
with a few dangers here and there he
breaks his bones right he has like 17
fractures you know he's like his left
lung is punctured and so on and so forth
but like kind of enduring these
struggles over and over and over again
it's just kind of the nature of of the
current situation that iron man is in
because at the end of the day korvac has
some kind of plan under his belt and all
these these guys that are being brought
in is being done for the purpose of
serving this plan now the question is
why because the next thing you see is
iron man who faces off against the
melter and the melter just like melts
his car and it's it's a weird thing
right it's almost like these guys are
kind of playing games with him screwing
up his head you know just kind of
appearing out of nowhere it's just kind
of small time stuff you would normally
never see iron man engage in a conflict
like this with these small time guys but
for some reason or another they're all
being brought together by korvac for the
purpose of facing off against iron man
unlike michael korvac in you know as he
originally appeared in the sense that he
was just basically a lazy guy right
existing in a future that was ruled by
the badoon instead like he's more or
less been kind of either recreated
manufactured whatever and is just kind
of going off his own schemes that makes
sense to himself and just basically
seeking godhood and that's what he tells
tony stark that ultimately we find out
that tony stark backed the experiment of
this guy not knowing it was korvac and
in doing that this entire process plays
out the way this guy intended it to
where essentially he kind of invites
iron man here iron man's like okay i
want to see what my investment bought me
and then as soon as that goes on he's
immediately hit by lightning right taken
out by this by by quarterback and then
corvac brings together the other guys
that have that have more or less been
freed right unicorn's been freed the
controllers here but it's kind of this
thing over and over where they're like
we're gonna take you out right i got
these three guys because they seem to be
the most equipped in taking you on now
this again is another kind of reflection
of the old school quarterback stories
because the reality is these guys are
not a challenge for iron man and they
never really were iron man was able to
overcome them pretty readily i mean guys
like the controller are kind of powerful
but they're all b or c list villains and
so it really seems more of an indication
that korvak is kind of learning as he
goes along and that was the nature of
the original quarterback once he stole
the power of galactus and was almost
really more machine than man even in the
events leading up to that he was kind of
figuring things out as he was doing that
and that's why the quarterback saga is
so cool because you see this guy who's
basically lazy who's turned into a
machine who steals the power of galactus
who comes back to the modern day and
then basically just kind of becomes more
and more of a credible threat as the
story goes on all the way up into the
point where he reaches godhood and
that's what this guy's trying to do
that's why him and korvac are really
linked in this way is he's kind of like
seemingly a remade version or returned
version of quarterback because he says
i'm not looking to achieve demi-god
level status i'll do that here in a
moment right i'll achieve this kind of
demigod level of power where i'm at
right now but i'm looking to attain full
on godhood that's his mission that's his
goal because that's what the original
michael korvac did
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with iron man yes we are you
guys really seem to love the video that
we did we were doing like the books of
corvac and the return of michael korvac
in marvel comics which admittedly is
pretty awesome but coming out of the
last video that we did right you had
basically patsy walker and iron man who
were taken out by korvac and at this
point it's just kind of recovery but in
the midst of all that you basically have
a couple things to go down the first is
that you have these kind of words that
are whispered in the ear patsy hellcat
right pray to the one for salvation pray
to the one for redemption pray to the
one for benediction just kind of these
words being whispered in her ear over
and over again and james rhodes has also
gone missing now for iron man himself a
lot of what's going on is kind of
backlash because well i mean because
it's iron man right i mean like when is
tony stark ever not screwing up in
marvel comics you know what i mean i
feel like ever since the events of civil
war everybody's got it out for tony
stark he's just always making mistakes
but more so than that pepsi walker is
basically dealing with the aftermath of
all this and the fact that she's got
fractal burns along her face as a result
of the lightning that she was struck by
now of course there's a couple you know
offers that are made by by stark and so
far saying well maybe reed richards or
somebody can tend to it and you know
keep it from scarring or whatever the
case is but the reality is that's not
really what's bothering patsy what's
really bothering her is these voices
that are kind of going in her head now
one of the things that's kind of hit on
here and one of the things that kind of
belongs to the history of her character
is the idea of schizophrenia uh it was
one of the things that baba focused on
in an effort to try to beef her up and
make her more interesting which is a
little weird when it comes to it
honestly it didn't work uh patsy walker
has never really been an interesting
character in marvel nothing against the
nature of a character personally it's
just that her stories were never really
compelling and so i just never really
had an interest in her at least that's
just my take anyway you might you know
find it a little more intriguing but one
of the other things that's really
concerning here for tony stark is the
nature of korvak and it's really one of
the things this kind of hit on here from
avengers 177 back in the day which was
the korvax saga right the idea that
michael korvac was basically a regular
human from from like the future of a
different universe where the badoon had
conquered everything and then in turn
because he was terrible at his job he
was you know kind of hooked up to a
machine and then basically ended up
taking over the power of galactus came
up to the modern era and then basically
made himself a cosmic entity right so
you know michael korvac has a history of
being this ridiculously op character and
in fact in the quarterback saga he
killed everybody right he brought him
back to life but he killed everybody and
that's one of the things that patsy
walker hits on and she's like look i
kind of get where you're coming from
here you know like he was a cosmic
entity and tony stark's like yeah i mean
now he's just kind of an android but
there's legitimate concern here right
because she's like it was it was you
know at that point when you guys fought
him he destroyed all of you and the only
reason you came back is because he
brought you back and that's true right
like like literally michael korvak saved
the day himself and was just kind of
like no this isn't really how it's meant
to be and then just set everything back
to normal and then just kind of
destroyed himself and wiped himself out
of existence but literally the bad guy
won by all standards of measurement it's
one of the things that made the corvette
saga so significant back in the day but
ultimately if you end up switching over
to james rhodes himself oh you know in
the the outer barrows of new york and
essentially he's just kind of being held
captive by michael korvac by way of the
controller himself now the controller
we've talked about him before over the
years in mobile comics the controller
basically has these little control disks
that he puts on people and they
basically bend them to his wimp the
biggest issue with this is that the
willpower of james rhodes is high and
it's one of the things that's been hit
on for years in marvel comics that
there's just something about james
rhodes that kind of makes him a cut
above the rest with everybody else and
so while the controller has three discs
on this guy james rose while i wouldn't
say that he can do whatever he wants to
he's still able to maintain some measure
of autonomy and it shouldn't necessarily
be that way right it's one of these
things where it's kind of like i mean
this guy should be completely and
totally bent to my control under these
discs but this guy's willpower is nuts
and a lot of that comes from james
rhodes own personal experiences as well
as having been iron man fought alongside
tony stark faced off against some very
heavy hitters some of which have the
ability of telepathy or the ability to
dominate the wills of others and so over
these years he's developed a kind of
conditioning even if not outright mental
blocks that basically make it very very
difficult for a person out there to
dominate his will or to subjugate him
and that's why while he's not able to
completely resist the powers of the
controller he's able to put up one hell
of a fight if we're being honest with
ourselves and so at the end of the day
it's one of these things where korvak
having this kind of conversation with
him is really more of in the end you
will bend to my will and even if you
don't it won't matter because once i've
reached to where i need to go at the end
of the day i'm going to be able to
conquer the universe anyway so it
doesn't matter whether you agree with me
because in the end i will rule
everything right i will control all and
so what you end up having here at least
the kind of goal of korvac is that in
its current form he doesn't have the
power to leave earth and reach his final
destination which is actually the ship
of tattoo of galactus world ship what he
needs is a kind of power boost he needs
the ability to have the power to leave
the earth and then storm galactus ship
and so what he's done is he's hooked
himself up to what is essentially a
giant power supply that'll allow him to
tap into the city's power grid and then
drain the entire electrical source of
the city itself into him and while that
may not seem like the most significant
thing remember one of the things to
understand is that korvac is by and
large a machine and so this is one of
those examples where christopher
cantwell's building into the idea that a
machine that controls an electrical grid
or can tap into an electrical grid could
kind of expand that to its near
limitless potential and that's exactly
what happens that once he's hooked up
and once he absorbs the city's
electrical power into himself that now
when when everything goes down right the
whole ship goes down that with patsy
walker kind of hearing these words of
michael korvac whispering in her ear she
picks up on the idea that he's pursuing
tattoo and that's when iron man really
begins to freak because he's like wait a
minute did you say tattoo and she's like
yeah and he's like that's galactus world
shift like oh my god so like with the
power going down that's when he realizes
that korvax tapping into the power grid
and basically following this he can
control all the electrons on earth right
he can literally control the earth the
entire world's electrical grid now this
is not the most important thing in the
world but it is a significant thing
because it's like it's like having the
abilities of storm when with storm she
can control the weather on any world
she's on with michael korvac it's the
exact same thing now being able to
manipulate the electric particles that
exist out there or electrons being able
to manipulate those on earth is being
able to manipulate those anywhere else
this is this is more or less akin to
like when neo and the matrix was
downloading knowledge of kung fu into
his body now the corvette can do it here
he can do it anywhere which includes
galactus the ship and so that's the idea
is to get there and then because
galactus ship runs on energy and
electrons in turn he'd be able to take
over the ship itself it's basically what
he did in the first appearance that he
had when he first took over and
downloaded everything in galactus ship
and gave himself the power cosmic and so
ultimately you end up having iron man
who goes to visit hellcam now you guys
might recall hal keon is the street
racer that iron man faced off against
when he was just going crazy and
spending money like a wild man but how
keon is one of these guys who of course
won uh is death therefore he uses sign
language but two because of the fact
that he is kind of an underground guy
insofar as illegal street racing tapping
into the underworld you know kind of
passing information back and forth he's
the closest iron man has to an actual
like underworld team what he needs is
something a little more complex the
problem with this is he can't just sound
the alarm to everybody right he can't go
out to like the the x-men he can't go to
the fantastic four he can't go to the
avengers because the condition of what
it is that michael korvac is doing is if
you tell anybody what's going on i will
kill james rhodes having to basically go
underground and seeing tony stark having
to operate without the help of like
avengers who will easily save the day
it's cool because it forces the story to
be written in a way where it focuses on
iron man in a capacity that you don't
normally see the problem is that in the
middle of all this a way in is a way out
if patsy walker can overhear michael
korvak michael korvac can control patsy
walker and that's what happens he
basically takes over the body of patsy
and literally tells tony stark do not
try to stop me right like do not try to
get in the way of what it is that i'm
doing now of course in the middle of all
this is with all the chaos and all the
pandemonium everybody's freaking out you
literally have haukeon who just like
picks up a hubcap walks over to uh to a
fire hydrant smashes off the the top of
it and just blasts patsy walker with
water and like that's it he's as calm as
a cucumber we end up finding out that's
his mutant power is that his heartbeat
never goes above 70 bpm now here's one
of the cool things man that's a genius
ability to have if your heart rate never
goes over 70 bpm you never panic right
adrenaline never kicks in you never run
into any of that stuff instead you're
always calm and if you're calm you can
think clearly and if you think clearly
you can win right and that's kind of the
cool thing so switch over to iron man
after he had gotten a hold of hao kian
and gave him a list of people that he
needed and we end up finding out this
list of people it's amazing right so
you've got gargoyle gargoyle doesn't
matter you got skull spider which is
awesome to see here you've got misty
night and then you have frog man eugene
patilio this guy sucks but his stories
or at least his origin is kind of cool
right so eugene patilio he was a marvel
team-up character he originally appeared
in marvel team up in issue 121 he
actually teamed up with spider-man and
with uh the human torch to any any like
accidentally defeated speed demon and
then when he defeated speed demon he was
like yeah
i'm amazing and then like went forward
and tried to be a superhero but
basically had a terrible career but i
love frogman i would love to read a solo
series about frogman i doubt it would
sell well it would last like six issues
and then marvel would cancel it but i
would love it
it would be amazing the reality is this
is a hodgepodge team man like this is
this is by no means the goal that tony
stark wanted but at the end of the day
he has to work with what he can where he
can now the true benefit in having this
group really comes in the form of misty
night because as you guys recall she's
the leader of heroes for hire or at
least she has been over the years but
she's also developed a lot of contacts
and so these are people that can feed
her information that cannot readily be
accessed by anybody in the superhero
community it's one of the aspects of
marvel comics that you never really get
to see explored all that often unless
you're actually reading heroes for hire
or something that has to do with misty
knight but there's a whole underground
network as grand and great as the
superheroes are you know the avengers
and all those guys there are times when
criminals will go underground and like
they'll never be able to find them
because anybody who could give them
information doesn't trust them but they
do trust misty knight but they do trust
luke cage they trust iron fist people
like that people who are on the ground
level and a lot of that is built into
the notion that because of the fact that
these superheroes fight on the ground
level in the same way these average
people do that it's kind of like you
know like they're one of us whereas when
they look at iron man they look at
captain america they look at thor they
look at those guys they're like they're
not one of us right like they're way up
there they see themselves as better
existing in their ivory tower and
avengers tower and just kind of a cut
above the rest of the world they see
those those high-level superheroes is in
a lot of ways being kind of haughty
right and so that's why you don't really
see like iron man being able to get a
hold of the same contacts that misty
knight has now he does have his own to a
degree but at the end of the day none of
it really seems to work out and so what
you end up having here these kind of
acolytes so to speak of of michael
korvac they all kind of band together in
front of this this giant ship and he's
like okay like grad james rhodes and uh
and like everything that we need will be
done in an hour and we basically need to
get the attention of iron man here and
so what you end up doing is you
basically pick up with the the team of
iron man right like you pick up with
misty night and all them who basically
come to this realization that there is a
kind of power source uh out in the dock
somewhere that basically had a high
level of radiation or energy that
emanated from it and so because of that
that's like that's their source right
that's where they need to go in order to
find poor back or at the very least find
whatever it is that has to do with
corvette and so ultimately you end up
having this location traced down by iron
man as it's given to him by misty knight
and when he gets there or at least gets
to a spot uh you know kind of following
patsy walker that basically these people
come running out saying that like
there's a guy in the laundry mat with a
bomb right and of course michael korvac
doesn't actually have a bomb he was
looking to just kind of get everything
sorted out with him and tony stark at
least you know get tony to not
necessarily be on his side but the very
least to understand that quarterback's
going to win now this is the thing to
understand here korvax not trying to get
iron man to his side he's not trying to
preach to him that like what i'm
actually doing is the right thing it's
really one of these things of like like
what i'm doing here is going to work
right like whether you wanted to or not
i will succeed here and there's
absolutely nothing you can do to stop me
he's like i've already imbued myself
with half the energy of earth right i
don't you know there's nothing you can
do to stop me here right like not you
not the avengers at the moment right now
i'm already more powerful than all of
you i am looking to achieve godhood and
i will bring unity to this universe
that's already so fractured and broken
what this universe needs is a singular
god under which it can either rally or
it can be forced to rally it can be
forced to bend the knee but one way or
the other i will be the one who rules
everything right he's talking like a
tyrannical dictator kind of guy and so
what you end up having while all that's
going on is misty knight and her guys
who were tasked with going and finding
that shiar jump ship which they
successfully do the problem is once they
get in there it's completely empty
there's nothing in there and tony stark
immediately putting two and two together
is like no get out of there and like
immediately boom the ship explodes right
takes all those guys out and it's like
holy [ __ ] like it's that's crazy right
like like literally it was a bomb that
was set up by uh by michael korvac and
that's the big difference between corvac
and tony stark corvac is just that much
smarter than he is and even when korvac
first showed up right he was a master
intellect across the universe and while
tony stark wouldn't necessarily give
himself that level of credit he is a
futurist he is exceedingly intelligent
but korvac in all of his appearances has
always just been that much more
intelligent than tony stark but
nonetheless korvac in in when he was
really a credible threat to the avengers
has always been wildly intelligent and
so as as smart as tony stark is in
comparison to the average person michael
korvac is that much more intelligent
than tony stark and being able to
outmatch him like this being able to
outclass him and just be like you never
really had a chance in the first place
like understand tony stark i've been
running circles around you since this
whole thing began tony stark lashes out
attacks corvac and uses every ounce of
energy that his that his suit can can
muster now something to understand here
this is also an old-school suit of iron
man so by no means is this kent while
saying like this is iron man in his peak
capacity using every ounce of energy he
has and the best suit of armor he has
and he still couldn't take out michael
korvac no i mean that's one of the
things we covered in the last video is
that it's a it's a vintage suit right
it's not his most up-to-date technical
suit if you were to face off and use
every ounce of energy that was available
in something like the indo-sim suit from
superior iron man he may have stood a
chance in taking out korvac here but at
the very least it doesn't matter the
result is that it's not enough and so
with him completely and totally drained
the responsive quarterback is tony
stark's out of the picture there's
nobody for us to worry about anymore
like get on board the ship we're on our
way to tattoo we're gonna go meet
galactus and we're gonna go take over
all the cosmic power that he has
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with iron man yes we are the
books of quarterback part two and this
one we're just going to cover the whole
volume right we're not going to worry
about splitting it a little section
things like that but coming out of the
last video that we did basically corvac
had launched an attack against patsy
walker and iron man and essentially
incapacitated them both which is just
kind of a sheer display of the power of
michael korvac so much so that tony
stark's entire suit is just shut down
right i mean it's just it's literally
been overloaded the rest of the team
writes like misty knight and frog man i
love frogman so like frogman gargoyle
those guys they're all kind of
recovering they were able to help sort
of guard people a little bit gargoyle's
kind of recovering himself right just
because of the fact that he lost a wing
sustained huge injuries different things
like that it's basically recovery time
and so when you end up picking back up
with tony stark uh what you end up
getting here is this this really cool
moment where they basically start to
kind of work on him as best they can but
they can't really do a whole lot and the
reason why is because of the injury that
he sustained this is one of those
interesting things about iron man suit
is that if they were to move him they
would like his his neck is like one bad
position away from killing him right
it's already broken right so in order to
keep him stabilized it's like having a
neck harness in the form of a suit they
have to actually modify the collar on
his suit so his body doesn't move and
it's one of the crazy things because
he's like under any normal circumstance
he would have this tended to they would
get it taken care of but michael korvac
trying to return to power is no small
thing now again because of the fact that
this is an iron man story under any
normal circumstance you would have him
enlist the aid of the avengers the
guardians of the galaxy the whole nine
yards but christopher cantwell is going
in the direction of saying like this is
just a tony stark story so is tony stark
just dealing with it on his own so
obviously this seems like it's going to
end in such a way to where quarterback's
going to obviously be defeated and he's
not going to become some massive
calamity right some universal wide
threat or anything along those lines but
in the midst of all this suddenly
they're met by the arrival of james
rhodes and james rhodes is kind of the
voice of reason here right donning the
war machine suit he's like look we got
to get the avengers in on this and the
response of stark is that's not going to
happen right i mean you do have one of
the henchmen of quarterback who shows up
tries to instigate a fight he gets taken
out pretty quickly but the whole idea
behind james rhodes is fine if this is
really going to be the case and this is
just going to be a you i've got to take
care of it on my own this is a personal
vendetta kind of thing then that's fine
like at the very least i can come along
and make sure that you don't get
yourself killed right that kind of a
thing now again people will kind of look
at that and say it's a little weird that
the camp wells turning this what is
basically a character who is a cosmic
entity right michael korvak at the peak
of his power was wildly powerful he
could reshape the universe as he so
chose based on his use of the power
cosmic right the power of galactus a lot
of people will look at that and say it's
weird that cantwell's just turning this
into an iron man story i think it's cool
i think it's cool to have a character
who is such a massive cosmic level
threat that's not turning into yet
another big crossover event in marvel
comics right where crossover events
happen all the time but instead it's
being held in the the kind of capacity
where it's facing off against iron man
this is old school right this is like
1970s 1980s marvel comics so while i'm
not necessarily some old school hipster
and i wish things could go back to the
way they were 50 years ago i don't i do
like the idea
that we get these kind of little moments
here where you get these small stories
where what would normally be a giant
avengers class threat probably even a
universal threat involving a whole host
of space faring characters and
everything instead of just being dealt
with by iron man so there's a couple
things you get here which is kind of
cool you end up of course getting them
you know boarding tony stark ship
basically taking off after michael
korvak uh war machine gets a giant
upgrade so does tony stark we're not
really given the definitive nature of
war machines upgrade we're just told
that he gets one and that's that's
really kind of it but you actually have
this really cool moment where you end up
having patsy walker who's basically
brought in alongside tony stark by
michael korvek of course using his his
powers and so on basically kind of
communicates to them that like this sort
of lush planet right this lush beautiful
planet is is kind of a physical
manifestation a representation of the
utopia that he wants to bring to the
universe and again this is one of the
things we talk about in like injustice
and different things like that that if
humanity and even just the entirety of
the universe's denizens wanted the
universe to be a better place it would
be but the fact that it's not is an
indication to the fact that they don't
want it to be whether it's by their own
inaction or their direct action and
keeping that from happening apathy or
intentional cause the result is that
people want things to be bad and so at
the end of the day korvac is kind of a
really appearing him you know as this
kind of guy that's saying look the
universe is going to become a better
place whether you want it to or not
right like war disease famine all that
kind of stuff hate fear it's all going
away i know a lot of you guys wanted to
stay but it's not going to right it's
all going to be eliminated and it's kind
of a funny thing because one of the
things that we've seen is like in the
face of that superheroes almost stand in
the way of making things better right
that if the world and the universe is a
crappy place because people out there
want it to be then in turn superheroes
saying no they should have the right to
choose whether or not the universe is
good or bad standing in the face of the
guy who's gonna say like i'm using all
this power to make the world a better
place is in effect standing in the way
of making the universe a better place
right so they're literally working
against progress like they're literally
working against the universe becoming a
utopia the argument that they argue that
they really present here is no one
person can have that power and the
argument that's really presented here is
based on michael korvac's previous
escapades which is his desire to kind of
lay waste to everything so on and so
forth which was not necessarily true the
funny thing about this is that michael
korvak is more machine than man so he's
not really encumbered by emotion and
really emotion is the source of
virtually every bad decision anybody's
ever made right emotional decisions are
inherently bad decisions logical
decisions are inherently the best
decisions right what's best for the
greatest number of people the greatest
number of people having peace and
prosperity and not having to worry about
pain and suffering that's what's best
for the universe
so we're going to do that right it's a
it's an interesting concept right it
really is this kind of you know freedom
versus security argument that's being
presented here and so because what you
get is iron man and essentially patsy
walker standing in the face of that the
whole thing is just kind of dispersed
and iron man is just teleported to some
weird location right just kind of sent
away where he's met by what's called the
colony patrol now we'll talk about them
here in a little bit but what you end up
doing here is switching over and really
picking up with like korvac and his guys
chasing after you know james rhodes and
you know trying to destroy their ship so
they can't get in the way of his mission
and all that kind of crazy stuff but in
the midst of all that suddenly patsy
walker is met by a telepathic
communication which actually turns out
to be coming from moon dragon now
heather douglas is interesting heather
douglas is cool she's probably one of
the more important characters in the
history of marvel comics
she is a hugely powerful telepath right
she has all kinds of wild abilities at
least on a telepathic level and really
depending on who's been writing the
story over the years if you go and you
look at the old school like jim starlin
stuff she was telepathically powerful on
a universal scale right if you look at
the more recent stories like dan abner
annihilation annihilation conquest she's
not necessarily on that same level of
power but she still is immensely
powerful more so than that her and patsy
walker have an interesting relationship
in the sense that in years past when
pakistan walker had these powers and it
basically started driving her insane
that moon dragon was the one who shut
those powers off and so what moon dragon
has done is realizing that because
corvak is returning here they really
kind of need all hands on deck and patsy
walker's ability to emanate telepathic
abilities or to the very least to ride
the radio waves of telepathic powers is
exceedingly important here and in fact
that's actually what saves the day
because while you do get this whole
thing where you get like the backstory
of patsy walker none of it really
matters her powers are basically woken
up right and so when you have korvac in
these guys who are basically chasing
down james rhodes and all them she uses
her powers to essentially spawn
illusions in the face of michael korvac
of the badoon right like his really is
his worst fear in a lot of different
ways we'll talk about why here in a
second but spawns you know illusions of
the badoon which really distracts
quarterback and everybody else enough to
where they basically stop dead in their
tracks which gives james rhodes and
everybody the ability to kind of fire up
their engines and take off as fast as
they can right now following that you
kind of pick up with this whole
quarterback thing right this whole
really discussion with with quarterbacks
so this really starts in the year 2997
right the quarterback is from the
far-flung future and technically an
alternate reality depending on how you
want to look at it but the important
thing is that by this point in time the
badoon have conquered a huge section of
the of the universe and it actually set
their sights on earth and so what you
had at that point was essentially a
rebel faction right these kind of
individuals out there who were looking
to stop the badoon from essentially
conquering earth at that point a lot of
humanity or at least some portion of
humanity works for the badoon really
more as servants and slaves than
anything else but the big thing is that
quarterback shows up here as part of
their ranks and then kills them all only
to find out that he's working for the
badoo right he's working directly for
them and that has essentially you know
eliminated this kind of faction this
this you know uh really rebel regiment
to ensure that there's no real
resistance nobody to warn earth that an
invasion of the badoon is coming now
again at this point in time korvac was
really just an employee right we're
really just like a servant working for
the badoon themselves and so what ended
up happening is that because he
abandoned his station and didn't do what
he was supposed to right didn't stay
there what they ended up doing was
taking his human components and
basically merging them with cybernetic
components and so he was one part man
one part machine he was a cyborg and he
had the ability to interface with the
machines this was the explanation marvel
provided as to how he became as powerful
as he was that in the original michael
korvac saga way back in the way back in
the day in marvel then what he did is he
actually traveled to the world ship of
galactus to tattoo and then quote
unquote downloaded the power cosmic and
that's what made him so powerful that's
what he's looking to do again right so
this is not michael korvac who's been
recreated as a character who just kind
of exists right just kind of a copy of
his former self this is actually michael
korvac who's been brought back and
that's kind of a cool thing now
something that's a little wonky is that
along the way to the the world ship of
galactus they're kind of recruiting
allies and one of the places they they
travel to is this world that's largely
kind of been been far-flung and cast off
only to find the original human torch
jim hammond now the events that led to
him being here really come out of like
the invaders comics we haven't really
covered those although they are pretty
good we may cover them at some future
point in time but one of the big changes
that kind of comes out of this one of
the things that's kind of given here is
that with korvac it's kind of a weird
blend michael korvac was basically
reinstated or brought back by the
enclave who created adam warlock and
called him adam but they call korvak
adam atom1 and the weird thing here is
that that korvac basically refers to jim
hammond as essentially being adam four
and so in essence it's almost as though
cantwell is kind of blending the old
phineas horton origin for creating jim
hammond with like the enclave and
creating adam warlock almost kind of
blending them together now as far as i'm
aware phineas horton was never part of
the enclave he never joined the enclave
right he was not really hell-bent on on
trying to conquer the world through
science if anything he was just obsessed
with getting credit for having created
the first android but regardless of how
you how you slice it here because of the
fact that jim hammond is an android
korvac approaches him because he
believes he's best suited to truly
understand what the mission of
quarterback is right quarterback's
desire to bring peace and prosperity and
so what you end up having is the two of
them traveling together and korvak of
course upgrades the body of jim hammond
giving him enhanced abilities but then
at the same time hooks him up to uh to a
system that basically allows him to
process and to see what it is that
korvac is looking to do now the two of
their minds are connected right because
as machines they can transfer
information back and forth in the same
way you transfer information from a
computer to a usb drive and so what this
does is it basically shows the the kind
of corvac events whereby the avengers
approach and they ask about what's going
on you know and they try to stop him
from what it is that he's doing and he
basically ends up killing the avengers
in the process and one of the things is
that when this happens jim hammond turns
on him and again this is kind of a funny
thing because the reality is whenever
you're instituting a giant cause like
this right like bringing peace and
prosperity to those who don't want it
they're going to try to stop it and so
as a result of that you're gonna have to
move them out of the way right there are
going to be forces out there that were
going to be roadblocks in your way and
ultimately if the ends truly do justify
the means and because of their own
natures they're incapable of seeing it
then you just have to get rid of them
right you literally just that's the only
thing that you can do if you cannot
convince them if you cannot get them to
understand where you're coming from if
you try everything you can which is
literally what quarterback's been doing
and at the end of the day they just
refuse to accept the reality of the
situation then the only alternative is
to eliminate them right to remove them
from the equation and then continue on
your goal to peace and prosperity it's
literally happened across the entirety
of of civilization and so because of
this korvak comes to this realization
that jim hammond will never really ally
himself with him and so where a
controller disc is put on hammond to
kind of keep him under control it really
is a little crushing to korvac because
he wasn't looking for a servant right he
wasn't looking for a slave he was
looking for an ally somebody that could
truly understand where he was coming
from and truly help him help him achieve
this goal and so it's kind of an
interesting thing here because having
the power of jim hammond is no small
thing right the original human torch
this guy's not necessarily on the same
power level as the human towards johnny
storm but he is pretty damn powerful
right he's pretty capable and so what
you end up doing is switching over to
this planet that iron man is currently
on and one of the funny things here is
that as he's in this world and as he's
there spending time with these people he
of course comes across a woman by the
name of yar who's basically the one that
leads the show now yar doesn't have any
real existing history in marvel she's a
new creation for this story but the
environment and the way this whole place
exists it really is by all standards of
measurement what you would define as a
communist society right there's no money
here right there's no real noble income
or anything like that they're simply
resources and those who share them now
truth to tell if this society grew large
enough you would either run into a
barter system that would evolve into
money or it would just turn straight
into money right you look at like any
any political philosopher out there and
they will tell you when you go from a
state of nature which is what this is to
an organized society then somehow or
another money's going to get involved
right it's just it's just the nature of
us as the human race we're primitive
right we are pretty primitive and pretty
basic and we haven't quite figured out
that there's more important things in
the world than cash so because of that
the the whole thing is that tony stark
kind of experiences this sense of
belonging that he never really
experienced before right this sense of
community camaraderie he even goes as
far as to say i never got along with the
avengers this well it's kind of a funny
thing now one of these guys is also
colin richards also known as avro x he
appeared back in marvel fanfare issue
number 44 back in the day he's it's okay
i mean it's not a major character right
it's not a great big huge thing it's not
a massive thing at all but while tony
stark is kind of exploring the area
waiting to be called forward by
basically the guy who runs the show that
he ends up coming across an ultimo now
the ultimo was nuts now ultimo was a
character who appeared in tales of
suspense number 76 back in 1966. the
ultimo was not like the biggest deal
ever when he first showed up but as time
progressed and especially when
characters like the mandarin got his
hands on him he became a became a host
right like the the ultimos are designed
to be insanely durable now the funny
thing about this is that initially the
ultimo only had like maybe 30
appearances in marvel comics so
christopher cantwell is by all standards
of measurement working with a blank
slate here he can kind of modify the
history of the ultimos as he sees fit
which is exactly what's going on here we
never really knew where the ultimo came
from we never really knew where it
originated from we just knew that it was
there one day and then it was being used
by different villains and it was
operating of its own accord it could run
it like 100 miles an hour it stood at
like 100 feet tall right these things
were were colossal in size but what tony
stark realizes that it is essentially a
machine powered organism he of course
helps to power or power his own suit
realizing that it's enzymatic along the
way right there are enzymes blended with
this technology so it seems to be partly
biological in nature and so while he
doesn't necessarily pick up immediately
on the fact that it's an ultimo he
realizes like this thing's got
biological components it's really more
of a passing interest than anything else
when suddenly he's met by the arrival of
yar who says like the big guy will see
you now and so when when tony stark gets
there he realizes it's wilbur day
it's the stilt man so stiltman was
created by stan lee and wally wood in
daredevil number eight back in 1965 he's
never been a big time threat in marvel
comics right i mean he's
literally as you see him that's what he
does right like he originally stole the
technology from his employer a guy named
carl caxton and then used it for his own
ends and you fought daredevil a little
bit ended up in a bit of a criminal
history there but he was never
significant right wilbur day was never
one of those guys where it's like oh my
god here comes stilt man that was never
gonna happen right it's like okay here
comes stilt man well you know he's he's
literally the guy that like that like
daredevil's fighting when the story
opens right just to kind of show what
daredevil's doing at the time that's
basically how stiltman was and and
really always has been in marvel comics
but the funny thing is still man hasn't
been seen in marvel for a long time and
that's one of the funny things here is
that as the two of them are kind of
talking iron man's like damn man like
like it's weird seeing you here his
knowledge of wilbur day is that he only
ever got involved with people if he
could achieve his own personal end right
he's really just kind of a jerk and so
iron man's whole thing is like okay so
like you're leading this whole thing
what do you get out of this right like i
mean what's what's in it for you he
expects him to be this villain that he's
familiar with but one of the things that
iron man quickly learns is that like
there's no room for that here right that
everybody's just trying to live right
they're just like they've all just kind
of been thrust here teleported here in
the same way that iron man has right
that somewhere along the line something
happened in the blink of an eye they
suddenly woke up here wilbur day was one
of the first but the character of yarr
she was a a she was a member of the cree
army right like a cree colonist and was
just like teleported here right
everybody's just kind of been yanked
here somewhere along the line this is
quite literally an island of misfit toys
right that's basically what this is
characters who are minor small
irrelevant never had any major role and
and there's no real logic or reason to
why they're here in the first place
honestly i love that cantwell's doing
this it's creative it's really really
creative i thought it was cool like this
never never would have occurred to me
and so the fact that everybody's just
kind of been yanked here and they're
just trying to live in this ecosystem
it's cool right because it's basically
really kind of showing the you know
these people for what they are if these
people really do anything it solidifies
the views of michael korvac right
they're like you can't have a utopia
like you can have this kind of
environment but notice like it's a cast
off these people never would have lived
in this environment had they not been
forced into it right the circumstances
led to them becoming where they are or
at least kind of living this life that
they're living in right so there really
is legitimacy to korvax argument here
right it's really kind of interesting
because even iron man finds himself
letting his guard down of course he
explains why he can't take his suit off
that if he does it'll break his neck and
he'll die but like he's just kind of
enjoying his life right i mean he's
literally playing baseball with him
right just kind of enjoying this utopian
lifestyle and just kind of chilling here
to the point that he almost kind of
doesn't want to leave but then suddenly
they're met by the arrival of one of the
ultimos who gets here and that's when
you kind of learn this little bit of a
dark history here when it comes to the
ultimos is that they one originated from
this planet and two killed the people
who created them right that this
basically seems to be the place where
they originated from and those
individuals who who created them were
ultimately destroyed and the way in
which these ultimos power themselves is
by basically consuming enzymes right the
reason why they're partly biological is
one of them basically ends up grabbing
yar and then eats her right like
literally consumes her and that's when
iron man realizes wow like this is this
is basically how it is they're
biological this story has an effect
turned into attack on titan
right those giant robots roaming around
eating people i assume that's what it is
i don't never really wash attack on well
i take that back vinnie over a comic
story and tried to get me into anime by
having me watch attack on titan it was
weird people keep telling me i should
watch it i mean i've seen like like full
metal alchemist brotherhood took me a
little while to get into it but you know
ultimately i got into it mariah got me
into that just because of the fact that
she watches it so often i have basically
watched the entire series of avatar the
last airbender even though i guess it's
not technically an anime but i saw a
bunch of those so i guess i might as
well sit down and watch you know attack
on titan right all these giant robots
who are just eating people i think it's
weird right it's weird the giant robots
are eating people but hey who am i to
complain about about anime being weird
but nonetheless
[Laughter]
it's one of these funny things because
with this ultimo being destroyed the
reality is that in this environment in
which they've lived that the ultimos are
basically the predators right you know
it's like it's like living in the living
out there in in africa and you have to
contend with like lions and different
things like that right those apex
predators that exist in that ecosystem
and then suddenly here comes iron man
and takes out one of the ultimos right
it's like the the age is a primitive man
when all they could do was run away from
predators and then suddenly men
developed spears right humanity
developed spears we developed fire
things like that tools and resources
that could be used that could elevate us
from from having been lower on the totem
pole to being the apex predator on earth
right it's really what's being
introduced here a modification to the
ecosystem and so iron man isn't
necessarily lawed as being like a leader
and like taking over the role of
controlling everything but it's one of
these things where it's just kind of
like okay you know it's like he kind of
looks around he says like so you say
there's more of these things out there
but what you've built here is something
beautiful right like we shouldn't let
those things destroy this right so what
we should do is go in and take care of
it right we should go handle these
things right he's almost kind of like
they're they're sort of field commander
their protector in a lot of ways because
in reality he's like i like it here
right i want to help you here and again
the kind of note that's left on here by
christopher cantwell is iron man doesn't
really seem to want to leave he kind of
wants to stay so with that being said
guys that wraps up the books of of
quarterback volume two i guess when i
will have to wait for volume three to
come out i'm loving it right i'm loving
what cantwell's doing with iron man i'm
gonna be honest this is some of the most
enjoyment i've had reading iron man's
comics since uh since really kieran
gillan's run right the secret origin of
tony stark and all that stuff the
introduction of arno and everything i'm
really digging like i'm really digging i
think it's some of the best iron man
writing since then
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with iron man and the the last
videos that we did it was kind of
interesting about this it is part of the
books of korvac but this is more of like
an interlude so what we might do in
order to keep things simple is we might
take this which is really the conclusion
of this little bit of an interlude we
might wrap it into the other two
episodes and make like a full story out
of it and then just throw it in the iron
man playlist to kind of keep things
simple so it's not overly complicated or
anything but while the main books of
korvac isn't necessarily done uh this
one has a great moment in this story so
much so that i kind of wanted to give it
my full attention which is why we're
sort of doing it on his own right i
don't really want to skim over anything
here but for those of you guys who are
getting caught up here the basis behind
what's happening in iron man right now
is that basically the villain michael
korvac has returned now a lot of people
who are familiar with marvel comics know
the name so bear with me for a second
for those who don't but michael korvac
is a very old villain in marvel comics
the quarterback saga is really one of
the seminal stories right it's one of
the most significant stories that marvel
comics had ever done but michael korvac
was basically a guy who ended up
attaining the power of godhood when he
essentially stole the power of galactus
and then ended up essentially fighting
the guardian of the galaxy from the year
3000 and then of course he also faced
off against the avengers right so it's a
really really significant story just in
terms of the marvel cosmic landscape
right the mobile cosmic hierarchy but
what had essentially happened is that at
the beginning of this korvac had
returned and then looking to reattain
his level of godhood was traveling to
the ship of galactus known as tatu for
the purpose of stealing galactus power
yet again and so that's kind of where
things are in the moment tony stark and
really his rag tag teams like misty
knight and sam wilson and you know
frogman and a few other people had
basically been assembled in order to
track down uh michael korvac and defeat
him but tony stark was essentially
thrown into this planet with a with a
kind of disruption ray which was
basically being led by long-time villain
stiltman and that was one of the funny
things these are really obscure villains
here and christopher cantwell's doing
that across the board even michael
korvac's henchmen are like b-list
villains right like none of them are of
any real significance the controller
people like that it's not as though it's
like michael korvac leading a team of
like thanos and all these guys it's
b-list villains right the kind of people
you would expect to see somebody like
hawkeye face off against right just
nobody of any real significance here and
so what had happened is that prior to
this one of the occupants of this colony
a woman named yar had been killed by one
of the ultimo robots so of course that's
one of those giant robots that seems to
originate from this world and just kind
of travels around the landscape just
eating things right so it's very
reminiscent of like attack on titan
right it's not that dissimilar except in
the show you have titans and in this you
basically have you know giant robots
which for the longest time i always
thought the titans were giant robots i'm
still not convinced they're not but the
important thing here is that with yar
dying along with several other people of
course they're basically holding a
funeral and that's where tony is
struggling because he's talking with
colin who is essentially the the chief
security officer for stiltman who's a
combination of like the spiritual leader
slash political leader i guess of this
colony and of course you know colin kind
of dealing with these these you know
issues and and so on the death of people
that they've basically grown close with
over time it hits them pretty hard and
that's when you have iron man who
basically goes and has a conversation
with stiltman and the funny thing about
this is that he asked him he's like why
don't we just destroy these ultimo
robots right like if these robots are
here i've already destroyed one we can
destroy all the others but the the the
explanation offered by uh by stiltman is
that these things seem to originate from
just some singularity out there
somewhere right like some machine
creating other machines but we don't
know if they're coming in from like a
different different dimension we have no
idea how all this stuff works all we
know is that they just seem to appear
and they basically travel around the
landscape and then basically kill and
consume whatever it is they happen to
come across and so at the end of the day
like yes i love your your desire to help
here but what we're better off doing
here is focusing our efforts on creating
what is in essence a signal beacon right
something that can basically sit on an
sos into the universe and someone can
come and rescue us right because for
right now tony stark's kind of stranded
here and in the midst of this
conversation he has a stilt man suddenly
he's met by patsy walker now remember
patsy walker is a member of tony stark's
team and that while the the crew is
still on that ship tony stark was
basically yanked away and that's why
he's here and so as a result of this
patsy walker is basically communicating
to him through like the ship's
technology and where you would ask well
why don't they just come here and pick
up tony stark the explanation is given
to us and it's actually a pretty solid
explanation that's given here that where
tony stark doesn't necessarily ask like
why don't you come and pick me up the
explanation given by patsy walker is the
mission is more important than you right
michael korvac represents a clear and
present danger to the universe if he
gets to galactus world ship before we do
and we have no discernible means of
stopping him right like basically he
overpowers us and presumably even kills
us he'll steal the power of galactus and
things will be right back where they
were before right where he recreates
existence that was the significance of
the original quarterback saga michael
korvac was so powerful the only way to
defeat him was for him to end his own
life like literally he destroyed himself
in order to set everything back to the
way it was supposed to be in reality
mama kind of wrote themselves into a
hole but that's how powerful he was and
that's the level of power that we're
looking at again right a person who
really seemed to go insane with the
power of galactus being able to recreate
reality as they see fit and so what you
have here is patsy walker communicating
with tony and saying one i know you've
turned off your morphine regulator
because remember tony stark's neck is
broken that's why he's staying in his
iron man suit is because if he takes the
suit off like if he takes off his helmet
that's the end of him right i mean he
said like literally his his neck is
hanging on by a threat right his spine
if it moves in a millimeter in the wrong
direction either he'll die or he'll be
paralyzed from the neck down for the
rest of his life and so keeping his head
stationary by keeping the helmet on
that's the only thing that's keeping him
from experiencing that thing and so
because of that he's just kind of
keeping himself doped up on morphine all
the time which really throws in this
idea that tony stark's not necessarily
thinking clearly or rationally and when
he tells patsy walker when she says like
no no we're gonna go deal with
quarterback the response to tony is no
you can't do that right if you do that
you guys are gonna get killed and your
deaths are gonna be on my conscience but
patty walker makes a really good point
here she's like no you can't take that
approach right like this is a choice
that we're making and if you say if we
go and fight korvak we are going to die
and it's something you're going to have
to live with then it takes away from the
choice that we make but it basically
says like we are like like mirrors of
you we're reflections of you right we we
do what you would do we're not really
capable of making our own intelligent
rational decisions but we know what
we're doing we know that we're going to
go after michael korvac we know he may
very well kill us and we accept that
fact right it's our role as heroes to
put the safety of individuals or
universes or the planet or what have you
ahead of our own lives to be willing to
make that sacrifice and so following
that tony stark becomes kind of
suspicious of everything stiltman was
saying and then offering this
explanation that like these machines are
coming from some singularity out there
the fact that they don't really know a
whole lot about them and so on and so
forth and so what he does is of course
he sneaks off to one of the machines and
when he gets to the ultimo robot he's
immediately attacked by colin and the
reason why is because as the head of
security colin wasn't really given the
details he was just told by uh by
stiltman make sure nobody gets close to
these things now the explanation i
imagine was probably offered if one was
even offered at all like assuming what
actually happened is well if you mess
with it it could send out a beacon to
the other ultimo robots and they would
all descend on us right like you would
bring death and destruction down on us
more so than that the citizens of this
colony trust stiltman implicitly they
don't really have a reason to question
him and so because of that they just
sort of go with whatever it is that he
says but tony stark knows enough about
wilbur to know he was a villain and so
while he may be telling the truth tony
stark's approaching this from the
perspective of trust but verify and so
when he shows up here and he's
immediately attacked by colin that tips
them off that either colin's working
with him or colin doesn't know what's
going on and so where tony stark gets
the upper hand on colin he's like what
are you hiding here what's going on
that's when colin spills the beans like
look i'm just doing what i was told i
was told to make sure that nobody got
close to this thing i don't even know
why but all i know is wilbur said
something about like the the balance is
fragile or something along those lines
and so as tony stark starts going
through this ultimate robot and
investigating it what he finds is that
it's actually being controlled remotely
right there's like an ir circuit right
an infrared circuit this thing's being
controlled and so that's what he
realizes stiltman is the one that's
doing this now here's the great thing
about this and this is what i loved
about the way that christopher cantwell
handled this this is one of those
moments when anybody could have just
been like well stiltman did it because
he's a villain and still man's like
absolute power like that kind of a thing
instead it's this great philosophical
argument you guys know i love these
kinds of these kinds of positions these
kind of discussions it's this right that
when tony stark runs them on stiltman
and is like you're the one controlling
these ultimo robots you're the one
bringing them here you're the one that's
causing problems here you know literally
the one that's getting people killed the
response of stiltman is essentially a
small price to pay in order to maintain
the balance this is game theory in fact
if we want to go with an example that's
probably more familiar to you let's look
at star wars knight to the old republic
right i don't know if you guys ever
played that game but when you're looking
for the star map on kashyyyk you're kind
of given these different game theory
type scenarios right the prisoner's
dilemma different things like that one
of the questions is this it says imagine
you are the leader of a nation consider
enemy states to be weak and remote with
no external threat your empire stagnates
your people become complacent and then
they begin to question you however in
your investigation of this attack you
discover a weakness that would come
after the attack and that weakness would
actually allow you to destroy the enemy
once and for all what do you do and the
answer to that scenario is you allow the
attack to happen because the people
would rally under you against a common
foe and that's really what stiltman's
talking about here now the reality is
stiltman's also engineering these
attacks but what it does is it unifies
the community in saying those ultimos
are a threat so long as we focus on
trying to find a way to get out of here
then everything will be okay now of
course the idea of sending out some kind
of an sos beacon that sort of a feeling
of comfort and safety the hope that
comes with that would only last for so
long but that's why you would have to
generate a new thing for them to rally
around and then a new thing after that
and a new thing after that that where
stiltman considers them to be part of
this ecosystem essentially he also had
his own personal ambitions which was to
prove that he could be a leader to prove
the idea that having individuals who
live these lives where there is no real
external threat out there and that in
the absence of any kind of external
threats that people would live up to
their fullest potential that that's
actually not true that if people are
given the opportunity to do whatever it
is they want to do with their lives and
to live their lives however they see fit
that they would ultimately grow to
become stagnant that they would either
do everything there was to do or they
would do nothing but the idea of having
this sort of external threat out there
that's always looming on the horizon
that while it does cause a bit of stress
and anxiety among the people it also
unifies them because if they're focusing
on an enemy they're not focusing on each
other and once that enemy goes away then
that's when differences start to crop up
that's when you don't believe what i
believe or you don't think what i think
right you don't feel the same way that i
feel about these things therefore you
are the bad guy that's how you end up
with strife and civil war so it's
actually a very smart maneuver on his
behalf to be willing to sacrifice some
innocent lives in order to maintain the
cohesiveness of the overall community i
mean is that philosophy a little bit
ruthless sure but it cannot be argued
that the philosophy works and so it's a
pretty interesting concept now of course
iron man and those guys basically end up
overcoming stiltman why they managed to
defeat him and that's basically it but
in the midst of him pleading his case to
them and telling them what's going on
that he essentially engineered a
circumstance whereby innocent people
would be killed in order to satisfy the
the livelihood of the greater whole that
all these individuals who have overheard
it kind of descend back into their own
selfish motivations where the response
is how dare you sacrifice innocent lives
to maintain this entire community and to
keep it from falling into a state of
civil war right what's your problem
and so all these guys basically descend
on stiltman carry him away presumably to
to kill him or destroy him or whatever
the case happens to be but the crazy
thing about this is that as colin and
iron man are basically leaving suddenly
tony stark's met by the most unexpected
person which is the living tribunal and
the living tribunal literally just
appears here and says tony stark right
and tony's just kind of shocked like
holy cow the living tribunal just
appeared to me right but the tribunal
says the universe is on the verge of
catastrophic imbalance only you can
restore this balance you must travel to
the world ship of galactus at this very
moment now here's the reality of this
this is one of the shortcomings of
christopher cantwell and not even just
him the shortcoming of marvel comics in
relation to how they use the living
tribunal where iron man replies and says
so from what you're telling me my
friends will not be able to stop
quarterback on their own i have to do it
the response of the tribunal is you
gravely misunderstand my words but you
still must leave right now and tony
stark says okay fine i'll do it but you
need to return all these people back to
their home which of course the living
tribunal does and then teleports iron
man and avro back to the or over to the
world ship of tattoo the world ship of
galactus here's the problem with how
marvel handles the living tribunal back
in the day when the tribunal was a major
player in marvel comics and i'm not even
talking about like his first appearance
of doctor strange even then he wasn't
even fully fleshed out he's like i
represent god or something like that and
like i do some stuff like the reality is
that as time progressed marvel flushed
his character out more and gave him an
actual role to exist in which is to
maintain balance of the universe and
that normally whenever there was any
kind of imbalance the tribunal would
either be requested by the various
cosmic entities like what you saw during
infinity gauntlet when they asked him to
rule against thanos and the response of
the tribunal was no thanos attaining the
infinity stones and then assembling the
gauntlet that's just a natural part of
the universe they exist in this universe
he's not abusing his power furthermore
if the goal of thanos is to take over to
basically destroy eternity and replace
him that's the natural order of things
right the weak make way for the strong
it'd be different if he had kind of
gotten some energy source from outside
the universe and then brought it into
the universe then that creates an
imbalance but using the tools the
universe provides in order to expand his
own power that's just the way it goes
but either it would be a situation like
that or it would be something like from
the the protege storyline where protege
had this level of power where he could
duplicate the powers of anybody and that
it would be different if he was born
that way but the reality is he was
engineered to be that way and so because
of that it violated the natural order of
things creating these kind of standards
by which the the tribunal lives and the
tribunal steps in it's weird to see the
tribunal show up and say yes tony stark
i am the walking talking embodiment of
the multiverse and i can wipe out whole
universes with a wave of my hand but
only you can stop michael korvak right i
mean it's it's like the rain telling
humanity only you can stop forest fires
right it doesn't make any sense right
why don't you do that rain it's kind of
what you do but that's kind of the way
the character has been portrayed over
the years if i'm being honest with you
guys the most recent and faithful
depiction of the tribunal came during
jonathan hickman's avengers and new
avengers and it's not because i'm just a
huge fan of that story but it's because
the beyonders in the multiverse killing
cosmic entities it's like some kind of a
virus in the human body it's a foreign
threat and so the living tribunal
stepping in and trying to destroy the
beyonders it makes the most practical
sense it's what it's supposed to do and
so the result of this is that the
tribunal has kind of been misused over
the years he's really sort of been
turned into a plot device more so than
anything else so while it is cool to see
the tribunal here the significance of
the tribunal being here has kind of been
lost on comic book readers over the
years because it's almost like the
tribunal kind of plays the role of a
watcher now right where when the
tribunal pops up i mean he's not going
to do anything but you know something
big is about to happen right and that's
really kind of how those things go
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with iron man from christopher
cantwell and initially i was going to
record this alongside uh the issue that
comes out on wednesday which is
basically the conclusion of the books of
korvax iii kind of the conclusion of
this this bit of an era but so much
happens here i kind of wanted to give it
its own video right and then we'll do a
follow-up video on wednesday with the
third part so i guess tomorrow at the
time we're recording this video maybe
thursday i'm not really sure the
important thing here is that basically
you now have iron man uh who's
essentially here on the the world ship
of galactus now again he's also
accompanied by colin remember colin is
one of the people who was on board the
the kind of plan that kind of community
that iron man was on in that little two
or three issue story arc that we covered
nothing super significant here uh but
he's here to kind of accompany him right
the living tribunal basically appeared
to iron man and was like hey man uh so
like you gotta go you gotta get to this
world show otherwise things are gonna
pop off
so him and uh and color were teleported
here now the big question that a lot of
people have been asking and i've seen
this in the comments a lot of you guys
have been asking what's going on with
galactus at this point in time okay so
we haven't really seen at least it's not
as far as i'm aware we haven't seen
anything resolved with galactus
following the events of donnie kate's
first story arc of thor so as far as
we're aware galactus is still gone but
he's still basically out of the picture
which is one of the reasons why his
world ship was so readily accessible
that's one of the things to remember
very rarely do you ever see galactus
when he's not on his world ship that his
worship serves as much a measure of
protection as it does a transportation
device or something like that it's
basically his home the whole thing about
this is galactus with him being out of
the picture it makes it easier for
people to arrive here now whether or not
christopher cantwell ties directly into
the aftermath of thor is something that
we're not really told here instead it's
really just kind of like the ship is
largely empty but just because galactus
is not here does not mean it's a it's a
walk in the park right remember galactus
has all kinds of safety measures along
tattoo and the first of these come in
the form of like drones and little sort
of basic security measures that both
iron man and colin are caught in now
colin is hit by one of these one of
these you know lasers and it's not
enough to kill him right but it's enough
to do a little bit of damage to him i
mean really he has his armor so that's
what protects him if it were just him
flesh and blood oh he would have been
incinerated but of course iron man and
colin working together are able to make
their way past all these different traps
and whatnot until they come across the
punisher robots now the punisher robots
i think are something that we've never
really talked about here on the youtube
channel and largely because we never
really had a reason to the punisher
robots are only ever really an option
you only ever really see them in marvel
comics when you're dealing with the
world chip of galactus but they've been
around for a long long time they go all
the way back to fantastic four issue
number 49 right like the original
galactus trilogy right they're just one
of the security measures here now the
funny thing about this is we don't
really know much about them all we
really know is that they are a form of
technology that galactus had acquired
somewhere along the line in the history
of the universe but by and large
whatever form of technology they came
from is largely believed to have been
extinct and that kind of makes sense
right when it comes to like alien races
and things like that in in marvel comics
multiple races regardless of their
technological advancements have largely
just come into existence and then died
out over the course of the billions of
years that the universe has been around
so this is just one of those little
things that galactus acquired over the
course of its time now they also have
the ability to duplicate their metallic
composition is something we're not fully
aware of but they're pretty capable
they're more than enough to go
toe-to-toe with people like iron man and
so on and so forth but of course tony
stark in a position where it's like
we've got much bigger fish to fry it's
one of these things where christopher
can't well doesn't really make them like
a throwaway thing he really presents him
as a credible threat to iron man it's
simply just we're in a rush we got stuff
to do so these things are basically
taken apart pretty quickly and then they
basically bail out now of course as one
of these things is being destroyed it
initiates a self-destruct countdown and
then just explodes right i mean one of
the things to keep in mind when it comes
to galactus world ship it's massive
right it's bigger than planets so
they're only in one little facet of it i
mean this thing goes on for quite some
time it's if you ever get a chance and
maybe we'll do a video on it i guess i
don't really know how we would do a
video on the world ship of galactus but
it is colossal in size right it's just
it's ridiculous how big it is but of
course once these threats are basically
dealt with iron man and colin kind of
make their way through the uh through
the ship itself until they basically
realize that there's another ship
inbound now initially iron man of course
hopes it's his friends right patsy
walker and jim james rhodes you know
iron man or at least uh war machine at
this point in time and a few other
people uh in reality it's the forces of
michael korvac now remember of course
michael korvac is trying to access the
world ship of galactus the same way he
did previously and turn himself into god
right that's really what's what's going
on here with this intention the crazy
thing is that of course a fight breaks
out between iron man and colin as well
as the forces of michael korvac and uh
and colin is destroyed quite readily
he's literally just obliterated i mean
just just totally annihilated by by
quarterback which of course pisses off
uh iron man iron man attacks and
actually rips the arm off of michael
korvac because remember he's basically a
robot at this point in time and then in
turn you know iron man of course is
basically overpowered by the forces of
korvac and so following that you
basically end up having like patsy
walker and you've got james rhodes war
machine all those guys who essentially
show up on the scene just in time to
save iron man from being destroyed now
one of the other things to kind of go on
here is that the forces of korvac could
have killed iron man but in his
arrogance michael korvac wanted iron man
to bear witness to him basically
becoming god one to experience the
complete depths of his failure in trying
to stop korvac and two to witness what
quarterback will do in terms of
recreating the universe recreating all
of existence and so there is a bit of a
conflict that kind of unfolds in terms
of these little hot shots and stop gap
measures of the forces of iron man to
try to prevent michael korvak and his
guys from getting to the actual energy
source of uh of galactus ship and
basically absorbing that power it's not
overly important here just kind of like
a few things here and there a few little
skirmishes the real big takeaway from
this is essentially once they reach
quarterback because he is basically just
a robot despite how capable he is they
were able to tear him apart now one
thing that did happen here is that
during his time making his way to the
world ship of galactus korvac did come
across jim hammond the original human
torch right the human torch before you
ever had johnny storm uh of course jim
hammond is an actual cyborg but using a
kind of controller disc that was created
by the controller it allowed korvac to
bring jim hammond under his control once
that disc was removed by patsy walker
once you realized it was there then
basically jim hammond turned coded
against corvac and then it's really the
only reason why they're actually able to
overcome quarterback in the first place
i mean you have like misty knight who's
shooting at them and so on and then
patsy walker's just sitting there
watching all unfold because what's she
gonna do and so you basically have like
jim hammond and you have iron man
that are blasting korvak with all the
energy they have which is enough to
seemingly destroy a good chunk of his
physical form right it annihilates
basically the skin off of his body and
then all that's left is his robotic form
which iron man of course punches through
the chest with the intention of
destroying him the funny thing about
this is that korvac basically plays
possum here that while iron man's kind
of like okay cool we destroyed
quarterback the day is saved and
everybody's kind of out there just sort
of like relaxing and they're like okay
we gotta find a way to basically you
know get off this thing right dispose of
the body that kind of stuff so we don't
have to worry about him coming back then
suddenly korvac just jumps up and lunges
directly for the the energy source of
galactus essentially giving himself the
power cosmic and in iron man's act of
desperation he does the same thing that
he basically puts himself in there now
this is one of the biggest developments
to come out of this this story by
christopher cantwell the nature of the
power cosmic when it comes to the power
cosmic in marvel comics it's it's
largely been ambiguous right marvel's
always just kind of said it's the source
of galactus power done right and that's
basically and that's that's really all
you get one of the things that's kind of
given here sort of sort of put here is
iron man kind of having his own
recording device right for his suit says
like record everything that i'm saying
here and everything that i'm seeing he
says the power cosmic from what i
understand scientifically it's the
primary substance of omniscience
omnipresence the collapse of space and
time into a singular energy matter
manipulation the removal of boundaries
between dimensions anything and
everything essentially what what looks
like christopher cantwell is saying here
is that the power cosmic itself is
basically godhood the ability to do
anything you want to do the ability to
like leave universes right to travel
from one universe to the next to control
anything and everything in all of
existence now in reality we would have i
mean if this is this is a new definition
for the power cosmic the question we
have to ask is why didn't galactus just
use it to its full potential right why
didn't galactus travel to alternate
realities travel to other universes
right some dead universe or something
like that you know why why is it that
the power of godhood is seemingly being
used in a limited capacity by galactus
and we have we kind of have to
extrapolate an answer right to sort of
delve into the realm of hearsay and
haphazard guessing i would argue that
this is because it's the role galactus
plays the galactus is a cosmic entity
that people like eternity and people
like infinity and master order and lord
chaos and people like that oblivion and
so on they're capable of incredible
feats but you never really see them
exercising those things the reason why
is because it's not their job to and
galactus job is to basically travel
around the cosmos and consume
life-sustaining planets in order to
basically propagate his existence in
years past marvel's tried to sort of
explain this with stories like the
abraxas saga and saying that if galactus
were to die he would unleash what is in
effect the representation of chaos and
destruction across the multiverse which
came in the form of abraxas it wasn't a
story that people took to very well so
mama kind of swept under the rug once
they ended it and that was it you just
never saw or heard from abraxas again
they've had stories like the trial of
reed richards where they basically
explained the role galactus plays across
the universe but then people also kind
of find themselves asking the question
if this really is basically the source
of godhood then why does a galactus just
like fill up on some source of energy
and then create a world that basically
is that he could essentially deposit all
that energy into and then take all that
energy out and just kind of live in a
sort of repeating pattern of like
consuming the energy of that world and
then giving that energy back to himself
so his power stays stagnant across the
board never increases never decreases
but he doesn't have to destroy planets
across the entirety of the cosmos if we
were to invoke the celestial's origin
which is really what marvel's doing now
right they're taking the origin of the
celestials from earth x and they're
rolling it directly into uh the main
marvel universe it initially started
with jonathan hickman and shield and now
has become kind of a mainstay in kieran
gillan's eternals that galactus's true
purpose is to travel around the universe
and basically destroy worlds that
celestials would normally deposit their
quote-unquote offspring into in order to
prevent celestials from overpopulating
the universe that's the role he plays
now but that's why you don't see him
using this this level of power to its
full totality because he's simply just
not supposed to and so once iron man
basically experiences what it means to
effectively be imbued with the power
cosmic reliving his own past going
through all these different moments
confronting his failures as a person and
seeing himself as he truly is once the
process is effectively complete he's
officially bonded with the power cosmic
he goes forward not in the same capacity
that michael korvac does which is to
bend the universe to his whim to do
whatever it is that he wants with all of
existence but instead to turn the
universe into a place where seemingly he
can actually improve it right it's one
of the things that iron man says right
he's like he's like this is my time i
have so many ideas i could fix
everything starting with myself but
that's just the beginning i promise you
it would all be so beautiful this leads
to him going back and confronting
michael korvac basically appearing as
iron man being god right cosmic iron man
right the iron god if you want to call
him that whatever the case is i mean the
guy has so many names and so once this
fight and this whole conflict breaks out
what we actually end up doing is
transitioning over to what is in effect
a priest basically him living on the
planet satania which really looks more
like a space station than a tried and
true planet but whatever you want to
call it right just kind of these these
this this giant space station sitting on
a on a piece of a dead world that
basically this guy kind of chronicles
everything going on right he talks about
like draconius he talks about the cosmic
entities and all that kind of stuff and
in effect we kind of jump back right to
this point when michael korvac and iron
man were basically fighting each other
that this guy living on this world had
basically lived on a very peaceful world
right but they were also capable of
shape-shifting different things like
that this idea that they basically just
kind of wanted to be left alone and they
were never really much of a threat to
anybody unless somebody made themselves
a threat right otherwise they were
largely pacifists but that their entire
world essentially ended when the fight
between michael korvac and iron man
ended up destroying a star right setting
a star to supernova and that these
people had minutes to evacuate in the
aftermath of this star exploding because
as fast as light travels in the midst of
an explosion in space it was only a
matter of time before it annihilated
their world and so what you have here
and this is what's kind of interesting
what you have here is a battle of cosmic
proportions between iron man as god
wielding this power cosmic and michael
korvak doing the same thing now here's
the funny thing to understand about this
the way a battle like this would
actually happen it probably wouldn't
really be fought in this way right it
would likely be fought by way of
something like the astral plane or
something along those lines but marvel
depicts the fight of cosmic entities by
having like worlds destroyed basically
like a street fight as if the street
fight took place and the battleground
was the was the entire universe in order
to illustrate the gravity of the power
these guys have and and one of the funny
things about this this all started with
jim starlin that it wasn't always done
this way but when jim starlin wrote
infinity gauntlet and the only real way
to depict the massive scale of the
battle that was taking place was for
like celestials to throw planets at
thanos in an effort to defeat him when
he had the infinity gauntlet it became a
mainstay of marvel comics and that's the
reason why and while you did kind of see
that beforehand a little bit that's the
reason why post infinity gauntlet when
you see a massive battle like this
between two godly beings that planets
are just caught in the crossfire stars
different things like that it's designed
to illustrate how massive this is right
i mean there's literally a point when
iron man gets the upper hand on michael
korvac and michael korvac takes a moment
to rest by sitting on a planet right or
by by kind of like laying on an entire
planet it's just it's designed to
illustrate the gravity of it all it's
really the best you can do in the world
of comics and it's one of those funny
things because the battle between them
is as much philosophical as it is
literal right in the sense that iron
man's like you have a small perspective
michael korvac your goal is to basically
conquer the universe and then turn it
into how you believe the universe should
function i have bigger ideas i've got
grander plans there's much better things
that we can do and so what's kind of
interesting here is that when that star
is destroyed and ultimately ends up
wiping out the planet of of draconius
that iron man actually comments on it it
was like do you even feel what it was
that you just did you annihilated a star
which wiped out basically the entire
solar system right and the responsive
core back is a necessary sacrifice to
stop your interference and that's kind
of the funny thing because it is right i
mean if you know most people i imagine
would look at this from the perspective
of oh my god he just destroyed that
entire star and now those people are
dead right but when you're wheeling the
power cosmic you can you can basically
reconstitute the star and resurrect
those people from the dead so are they
really dead in the first place right
it's one of those kind of moral
philosophical quandaries if you have the
ability to resurrect a dead person back
to life in their original state before
they were ever killed was it morally
wrong to kill them in the first place i
mean it's one of those weird little
quagmires that you kind of find yourself
dealing with whenever you're looking at
stories and comics one of the many
reasons why i love comics so much but
the whole idea of iron man is i don't
intend to wipe out entire civilizations
in order to make the universe better we
don't really know what his motivation is
or at least how his plan would unfold we
simply just know that he doesn't really
want to destroy things or even just like
recreate all existence in the same
capacity michael korvac does and so
realizing that this fight within this
universe would lead to just massive
calamities and all levels of destruction
this basically leads to iron man
creating a portal to another reality to
another universe and sending michael
korvac through the funny thing is that
once he sends them into this universe we
don't really get an explanation of what
universe this is we're just told it's a
dead universe where seemingly everything
in this universe was destroyed we don't
know how it happened we don't really
even know why it happened we simply just
know that it did this is not the cancer
verse right if this were the cancer
verse it would be filled to the brim
with life right i would just it would
just be ships everywhere and all kinds
of stuff the mini angled ones would
probably immediately seize on on michael
korvac in iron man and just subjugate
them and in truth despite the power
cosmic that they have they really
wouldn't be able to stand much of a
chance against those guys i mean
galactus in that universe had the power
cosmic and he was destroyed they
literally turned him into the galactus
engine those of you guys who don't know
what i'm talking about thanos imperative
was a ridiculously great story where
like they turned galactus into a machine
like into a just into what's basically
just a giant cosmic gun it's crazy
it's absolutely nuts but with this guy
you know but of course i'm kind of
telling this this story in the past
tense with him basically observing right
this piece observing this fight between
michael korvac and uh and and iron man
the fight is just colossal and scale
right huge amounts of energy being let
off and then in a moment when michael
korvac is just kind of temporarily
knocked out or however you want to see
it when it's a bit of a reprieve iron
man realizes they're in a section or
they're in the the saul system right
like the milky way galaxy and he sees
earth that earth looks like it was
basically just destroyed right i mean
it's not really destroyed in the
physical sense just like devoid of life
and he realizes that like that's a fate
that could potentially befall the world
because of humanity's own actions or an
alien invasion or something like that
and he's like i will help my universe
right i will help my universe become
better than it has been and so when
michael korvac goes on the attack the
response of iron man is i'm sorry korvak
it's my turn now and just bam just like
attacks this guy and he doesn't
necessarily destroy him or at least it
may seem like he kind of destroys him
but what it does is it basically meets
with the arrival of the cosmic entities
now here's the thing right it's the
cosmic entity sure like eternity and in
death and like you know sire hate and
mistress love and like the in-betweener
and infinity all that kind of stuff the
big thing here is oblivion and the
living tribunal show up here and it's
kind of like like literally the tribunal
is like this battle ceases now right
this battle ends now right this is this
is done right this whole thing is
finished like you had disturbed the
natural balance of things michael korvak
you have seized a power that does not
belong to you and elevated yourself to
godhood you will come with us now here's
the funny thing about this is that could
the tribunal particularly have involved
himself at any point in time sure right
the power of the living tribunal trumps
the power of of the the power cosmic or
at least it seemed to be that way right
maybe that's not the case anymore right
it looks like christopher canwell is
kind of toying with the the cosmic
hierarchy in marvel comics right that a
wielder of the power cosmic is basically
a person who wields the power to do
anything and everything with no limit to
the things they can or cannot do right
when you're dealing with cosmic entities
sure they can do a whole lot of stuff
but eternity's power is limited to the
universe that he represents he can't
alter a different universe because he's
the physical manifestation of the
universe it's like the color red being
able to change the color blue unless you
mix the two together it's not going to
happen they're just two distinctly
different colors but the important thing
is that uh is that the cosmic entities
basically step in and they're like we're
done right they ultimately end up taking
michael korvik away now the question
that's asked here really comes by way of
master order when he says like what do
we do with iron man right this guy has
been imbued with the power of the cosmos
itself like he could open portals to
other other realities the guy could
basically do anything he wants to now of
course mistress love says give him trust
sire hate says give him pain and then of
course mr's death is just like kill
right you know because she's obsessed
with death and even oblivion steps in
now the funny thing about this is that
it appears that the statement of
oblivion trumps the statement of
everybody else oblivion says it matters
not what we give or do not give the path
has been set so says oblivion and so at
that point the tribunal basically steps
in and says presently your future is
clouded right but the ultimate outcome
may be satisfactory to us and so
ultimately the cosmic entities take
michael korvac away and iron man himself
basically returns to the main marvel
universe and so in the end what you end
up getting is this priest of course
again who crash lands on satania after
escaping this dead reality and and
witnessing this meeting of the cosmic
entities and so on and just kind of
recording everything that's happened
here basically kills himself
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with iron man from christopher
cantwell and we are covering this point
where basically iron man has essentially
become god right where he's basically
have the powers of galactus and
seemingly the power cosmic in its
totality and the result of this is of
course a little bit of time has passed
in the sense that you have like war
machine right you got james rhodes you
got the original human torch patsy
walker and all those folks back on earth
and they're kind of having a
conversation so one of the things that
is easy to
i wouldn't say misinterpret but easy to
forget when it comes to the various
cosmic beings that exist out there in
marvel comics is the nature of time that
time is relative to cosmic abstracts in
fact with the exception of people like
galactus and infinity because she
represents the nature of it time doesn't
really matter the cosmic entities the
cosmic entities appearing in the year
1900 is really no different than them
appearing in the year 2000 right because
for them things just simply exist right
i mean there is a point whereby the
universe will begin and the universe
will end but marvel never really gives
us this idea that cosmic entities really
care about the concept of time and for
someone like tony stark right when he
had undergone the process of
experiencing what it meant to undertake
the power cosmic to have that power
given to him and then go through the
whole process of being imbued with it
that time had passed but we were never
really given how much time had passed
because that's designed to kind of
mirror how the cosmic entities see
existence right just a seemingly series
of successive moments but no real
differentiation between how much time
passes between each individual moment
it's just a series of things that take
place it kind of makes sense not a super
important thing but it's good to see
that christopher camwell sort of notices
this but of course at that point tony
stark does arrive on earth and when he
shows up here it's very reminiscent to
how you would expect galactus to appear
or character that imposing now it's also
kind of feeding into the ego of tony
stark a little bit and in fact what he
does with this power is kind of funny
here in a little while because he
shrinks down to a more reasonable size
right that people can kind of comprehend
and they don't necessarily find so
intimidating and then in the midst of
all that as he's talking to james rose
there's not really much of a
conversation here right like he's
literally there for like two seconds the
avengers show up alongside the fantastic
four and the funny thing here is that
they don't quite know what to make of
tony stark and the reason why is because
while tony has done some things a lot of
them are also familiar with the things
that tony has done right so take for
example the idea of the infinity
gauntlet one of the things a lot of you
guys may not know is iron man's had the
infinity gauntlet and in fact iron man
got the infinity gauntlet off of parker
robbins the hood when the hood got the
infinity gauntlet now of course the
other members of the illuminati knew
what was going on because tony stark
taking it and then telling everybody
else who was there uh these gems need to
be taken care of it's too dangerous all
that kind of stuff was really him taking
it and then the illuminati splitting the
gems among themselves but the important
thing is they know how shady tony stark
can be and when you take like the
shadiness of tony stark and then you
combine it with basically godly power
who knows what he's going to do and
that's one of those things where like
they start to question like what are
your motivations here right is michael
korvac still a threat of course at the
end of the day he's like you know
michael korvac is basically defeated but
when captain america asked the question
well what about you are you a threat his
response is well that sounds awfully
loaded and steve's like i'm very
concerned and so in the end his response
is well i mean can you relax right we've
all dealt with gods before look at thor
right it's the exact same five and
thor's like no we're not i'm totally
different here
this is a whole different thing and so
the big question people have is what's
tony stark going to do with this power
and so what he does is he makes this
amazing speech right this amazing
impassioned thing and he says okay well
korvac was right and wanting harmony but
wrong about how to get there he believed
that he alone knew best he put himself
and his opinions above others and then
he asks him he has the avengers he's
like doesn't that sound familiar to you
guys and he says korvak was wrong to
hoard his intellect wrong to want to
take away free will from everyone else i
had the infinity gems once but i wasn't
going to force anything with them and i
won't now either but then how does one
make something harmonious while
preserving the individual and he says
well i looked at my own gifts i'm
talking about the things i had before
these new powers i thought of solutions
and ideas i've had in the past and how
they've gone awry and i realized
something they didn't work because they
were trapped in here in my head but now
what's in here doesn't have to be
trapped inside anymore it can be shared
as a gift now the funny thing about this
is that there's a kind of irritable
moment that takes place right and this
is the thing that kind of gives people
pause for concern is that captain
america keeps interrupting iron man and
saying wait like hold on man like here's
the thing and his iron man is trying to
make his point captain america keeps
interrupting him trying to trying to
literally make his case and the response
of iron man is let me finish right and
just kind of like grows to this huge
size now i understand this is not iron
man getting carried away with his power
this is iron man being pissed with
captain america because the point that
iron man was making up until this moment
is that there's a kind of hubris that
comes with the avengers yes they're as
much street level heroes as they are the
earth's mightiest heroes saving earth
from various threats and saving some guy
random guy on the street who's being
mugged by somebody else but there's a
hubris in the avengers in the sense that
because they're superheroes and because
they've saved the earth from so many
threats and they do good things they
know what's best and so captain america
in the eyes of iron man embodies that
hubris more than anything else i'm
captain america i've been around for a
long long time i have great battle
strategy and i know how to organize and
galvanize the superhero community
everyone should listen to me right that
kind of irritation now of course a lot
of it's also just because these guys
have just had a sketchy history ever
since the events of civil war but what
iron man says here is my gift is now in
all of you my intellect my level of
aptitude it's yours you are all now
stark level geniuses but it's kind of a
funny thing because the whole question
here is well what if we don't want it
and he's like well i mean it's too late
right it's done you're all now as
brilliant as i am and so is every living
person in the city and he says i figured
we'd start with a small sample size and
see how it goes he says i don't want
things to get too far ahead right i
don't want this experiment to be
something that i effectively lose
control of and the funny thing here is
susan asks reed she's like what do you
think reid like do you feel any
different he's like actually i feel like
i just became less intelligent
but all across the city of new york
right queens these different places that
you have these arguments that are going
on between couples right between people
and as they engage in these arguments as
soon as this power is given suddenly
it's a series of like introspection well
i'm saying this to you because i am
actually feeling this way but i'm not
telling you i'm feeling this way because
you know and so on and so forth it's
people kind of coming to terms with what
they're really thinking and then voicing
what it is they're really thinking not
only that it's people becoming geniuses
like in the boardroom offering solutions
that hadn't really been given before
right throwing out these things like
carbon based nano quadrature that
atomizes the hydrogen into particles of
energy and i don't even know what that
means but the thing about this is that
people are basically just incredibly
intelligent and this is a really really
interesting concept because what this
does here is it's tony stark showing up
to the world and saying i am not going
to make the world better i'm going to
give the world the opportunity to make
itself better i'm going to give people
the opportunity the means the
intelligence to improve the world and to
make it a better place and so it's a
genius idea because what you do is you
effectively box people in right you box
humanity in you take this section of new
york and you say okay with everybody
becoming more intelligent now if this
place doesn't get better it's because
people don't want it to get better
because with this level of intelligence
this is going to have to lead to
compromise because people will realize
okay my particular solution won't work
perfectly but maybe a blending of five
solutions will right just things along
those lines now of course the funny
thing about this is that at that moment
you basically have big wheel who just
wakes up out of a coma right now as far
as i'm aware big wheel ended up in a
coma because you know the events of
deadpool and the merch for money number
four i don't really know a whole lot
about this guy i mean the guy's
literally driving like a giant big wheel
through the city of new york right just
seemingly causing all kinds of of crazy
commotion and pandemonium and it looks
like he's just using his intelligence to
engage in like some villainous schemes
of course the entire time this is going
on iron man is effectively being yelled
at by patsy walker like are you really
sure that this is a good thing to do
right i mean you're basically taking
what you deem to be the right thing to
do and then imposing it across the world
and so on and so forth but then like big
wheel basically gets their attention and
this guy is just like running through
and causing all kinds of crazy things
and the funny thing about that is like
like patsy walker's like is big wheel
typically a technologically organized
maniac wielding selenium encoded
infrared signal beams and you know i
understood some of those words and like
the response of iron man is like no he's
usually just a guy in a big wheel
and here's the funny thing about this is
that once they finally catch up to him
and once they finally stop him they
realize that while he does shoot patsy
walker in order to make her get out of
the way which is a kind of a dick thing
to do it's a villainous thing to do iron
man of course brings the whole thing to
a halt and then realizes that what big
wheel was doing was solving the problem
of traffic issues in new york he was
solving the problem of gridlock right
like he literally fixed all the traffic
problems in new york city that people
can basically travel throughout the
entirety of the city as you would in a
normal place right in a normal location
he says hey this guy just solved traffic
congestion that's truly groundbreaking
man
that's a pretty big deal and so it's one
of those funny things is because this is
how some people are basically going to
use their powers right and so as a
result of this what you get here is
patsy walker screaming at iron man right
and where iron man's trying to plead the
case and sing like look like what i'm
doing here is working you're welcome
like what else do you want from me her
response is how about some foresight the
world doesn't simply become instantly
better just because we all think like
you do now and of course that pisses off
iron man who in turn says even with the
incredible capacity of my mind you
whimper with small-minded doubt i will
fix this entire world just watch me and
in that moment patsy walker's like
there's nothing to do and so patsy
walker basically just walks off and so
as a result of this she goes to the only
person that she really can go to when
you're dealing with someone with just
incredible levels of intelligence and
power only one man is capable of
bringing that person down someone of
equal intelligence and equal aspirations
for high levels of power she goes to
victor von doom and says you need to be
the one to bring iron man back down to
our level to well in all honesty you
need to be the one to stop iron man from
trying to fix the world but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace